vos hésitations la différence de vue que
l'on vous prête avec le président de la
république
l'absence de ministre de l'intérieur le
fait que certains ministres soit sur le
départ forcé depuis dix jours d'ailleurs
je remarque que moins la moitié de votre
gouvernement est présent sur les bancs
du sénat
la confusion empêche de parler de
l'essentiel la politique que vous menez
vous avez annoncé 20 euros mensuels le
décret qui vient d'être publié reviens
une augmentation réelle de 8 euros
allez vous bloquez longtemps les
salaires des fonctionnaires alors que
l'inflation fortement est de retour et
la même question se pose pour les
revenus sociaux
ce premier ministre je n'ai pas longer
la liste elle serait longue et elle
aurait dû relever d'un débat de
politique générale
elle aurait dû relever d'un débat de
politique générale retenez seulement
cette question est ce que la vie
quotidienne des français de plus en plus
nombreux à ne plus vous croire va
changer avec votre remaniement vous avez
commencé votre question en évoquant la
portée politique que pouvait avoir tel
ou tel remaniement et en indiquant
probablement fondée sur une expérience
que nous avons tous en tête qu aucun
remaniement ne pouvait à lui seul
changer une bonne politique je suis
persuadée de cette idée depuis longtemps
et encore une fois l'expérience me
conduit à vous donner raison plus
exactement
l'expérience que vous mentionnez ou que
vous avez vécu me conduit à vous donner
raison
permettez moi monsieur le président
puisque vous nous avez interrogé sur ce
qui change
permettez moi de vous indiquer que
depuis quelques jours les français
reçoivent leur feuille d'impôt et il
voit
et il voit monsieur le président et il
voit monsieur le président que la taxe
d'habitation a effectivement baissé pour
80 % des contribuables
les lignes directrices de la future
réforme des retraites ont enfin été
dévoilés
en effet votre projet de fusion des 42
régime actuel est de mise en place d'une
retraite par points va réduire les
pensions des travailleurs est repoussé à
63 ans par un système de décote l'âge de
départ effectif à taux plein ce sont les
mécanismes de redistribution et de
solidarité que vous remettez en cause au
profit d'une logique d'individualisation
fait peser à l'assuré tous les risques
du montant de sa future pension
aucune organisation syndicale n'a osé
tenir les propos que vous tenez dans
cette assemblée à aucun moment
à aucun moment il a été remis en cause
un système universel de retraite par
points de retraite avec une part
importante dédiée à la solidarité toutes
les organisations syndicales ont reconnu
que nous couvrions de nouvelles
solidarités qui n'existait pas dans le
système actuel
à aucun moment il n'a été question de
reculer l'âge de départ à la retraite
tels que le président de la république
s'était engagé les partenaires sociaux
ont tous reconnu que ce mode de
concertation avait été particulièrement
fructueux et permettait d'engager une
nouvelle phase sur de nouvelles
questions qui vont être posées
concernant notamment la gouvernance du
futur système et deuxièmement concernant
la modalité de transition du système
actuel jusqu'au futur système
[Musique]